ما هو حيادية الشبكة التي لا
علاقة لها بملعب الكرة الطائرة أو التنس ،
تشير الشبكة إلى الإنترنت إلى
شيء أصبح ضروريًا مثل الماء
والطاقة بالنسبة لمعظمنا ، يتعلق جزء الحياد
بالحفاظ على الشبكة كما هي
اليوم.  القواعد التي دخلت حيز
التنفيذ في عام 2015 لمنع مصائد السرعة على
طريق المعلومات السريع ،
بمعنى آخر تسريع الوصول إلى
بعض المواقع وإبطاء الوصول إلى
مواقع أخرى أو حظر مواقع معينة
تمامًا ، لذا فإن هذه القواعد
السيئة تعتمد على من تسأل  لقد أنفقت الشركات
التي تقدم الإنترنت الخاص بك مثل Comcast
Verizon و AT&T الملايين في
الضغط على الأموال للتخلص من
حيادية الإنترنت بحجة أن جعل
الحكومة تدير أعمالها بشكل دقيق
ليس مفيدًا لهم أو لعملائهم على
الجانب الآخر من عمالقة الإنترنت لدينا مثل
Facebook و Google.  خدمات
مثل Netflix والرئيس السابق أوباما
يجادلون جميعًا بأن الإنترنت هو منفعة عامة
ويجب تنظيمه مثل تلك
التي هم أيضًا  لنفترض أن الشركات التي تمتلك
خطوط الأنابيب يمكنها اللعب المفضلة ، على
سبيل المثال ، فإن مزود المحتوى مثل
Netflix في منافسة مباشرة مع Comcast
التي تمتلك NBC Universal وتتحكم في
الوصول إلى الإنترنت لأكثر من 20
مليون عميل ، يمكنك تخيل
سيناريو تريد فيه NBC
تسريعها  بث مباشر من عروضها وإبطاء
تدفقات منافستها Netflix الآن
يمكن لـ Netflix دفع ثمن المسار السريع الذي
تبلغ قيمته أكثر من 70 مليار دولار ،
لكن Netflix القادمة هي شركة ناشئة رائعة
[موسيقى]